[Music]
I'm Cara Santa Maria for wired with
Norman Reedus who plays Daryl Dixon on
the walking dead so how's it going
that's going good walking dead I mean
this is a huge phenomenon obviously
getting to your character do you
identify with him you know I mean I'm
awkward like him you know I have trouble
expressing my feelings like him
if you drop me off in the middle of the
woods I'd probably just curl up in a
ball and cry no survival instant zero
like none you know it yeah so you do not
think you'll fare well in Islam be upon
not unless there's an uber uber car
close to me I'm kind of a wimp yeah I
mean I tell people I just I'd probably
break into a hotel and watch South Park
until I just started up why don't they
ever do that in the show I don't like a
good idea I guess would be boring to
watch somebody watch South Park but no
I'm not I mean in some ways I am and I
bring a lot of myself to the character
and they're very gracious with this too
you know a lot allow us to put our own
input into the character and where the
storyline goes you know to a certain
extent and then sometimes they're like
Norman shut up that's the worst idea
I've ever heard in my life
so I mean it's a given a take and it's
you know it's it's there's not a weak
link in our chain right now so it's it's
a great job and thank you so much for
being with me
[Music]